today's topic jubilee and the title is
is it ever too much makeup
i'm passionate of makeup because it
allowed me to
showcase to the world at a very young
age the woman that i
always was a lot of people think just
because i wear makeup i'm really stuck
up
and i feel it allowed me to show to the
world the woman i really was
is womanhood synonymous with makeup
because we we talk all the time about
gender roles right and we often talk
about how bad they are
how detrimental they can be that they
put people in a box yeah but then we
also constantly try to define the box by
saying
womanhood includes makeup yes or
womanhood includes wearing
dresses or whatever i'm just confused by
the messaging you know what i'm saying
like that's one thing maybe i'm i'll
probably admit i'm pretty ignorant on
this
topic but you know when this whole idea
of transitioning and then acting
like i'm i'm living as a gender that i
feel i am all right
or i believe in myself right what does
that mean to
live like a woman i suppose does that
mean that somehow
that person's trans from what i
understood and so i just understand like
how do you
how do you say like all right i am and
and part of being a woman means wearing
makeup
you know what i'm saying i'm just asking
the question
i don't know
women are oppressed by today's beauty
standards
it praise or it being the beauty
industry and the cosmetic industry
preys on the insecurities that women
and men as well feel for example with
aging wear this foundation use these eye
creams do this that the other thing so
that way
you don't look like you're aging and i
think that
the aging process is a beautiful thing
and it should be celebrated and it just
shows like all of the life that you've
lived and i think the sole
fact that there is a beauty standard in
general
is just so damaging because i just see
beauty in a lot of people
there shouldn't be a standard for your
natural self that you are
what do you think about the question
what about the question what would your
answer be
oh yeah women are oppressed by beauty
standards yes they are go on
certain women are going to lose their
job just because of the way they load
they're going to lose
their job because they're they're they
are like they are aging if you're
working tv or entertainment you got you
know there's ascend
a standard they're going to replace you
because of your looks you know they're
going to be
maybe if you take a news anchor or if
you take a sports anchor
whatever if you take a male he's going
to be judging some things but the woman
is going to be judging her looks and
stuff like that
yeah there can be oppression about that
it could i guess it's a barrier
i think oppressed is such a strong word
because we like you know but here's what
i would say if there's a privilege then
there's a form of depression
there's beauty privilege yeah this is
not my opinion it's not his opinion this
is like
quantifiable like sociologists have
already confirmed it yeah the more
attractive you
you are the more privileges that you
have better access to jobs better access
to finance
mates all that good stuff right so
by virtue if they're getting something
just on that
virtual loan then the people who are not
yeah you know
sure would i use the word oppression no
but there's definitely disadvantages and
so as a result i definitely think
that um uh it's an issue and when it
comes to women i think it becomes even
more so
because the fact that looks from women
matter even more than they do for men
they just do in every facet of life
dating work all that good stuff
and the truth is a lot of us are going
to be born and dealt a shitty hand in
that regards yeah
i don't necessarily think beauty
standards are oppressive but i think
sometimes they're unobtainable
so for example like i've always
struggled with acne scars and i was like
looking on social media and everybody's
skin looks like
so even and so clear but then i learned
that there are a lot of filters that
will actually do that like i only
discovered this two months ago
and then i used one and i was like wait
no i look like everybody else
and i thought everybody just had like
beautiful poreless skin and i was the
only one left out
when you guys will post like your makeup
look
do you guys use filters on them i've
always been open
with all my followers that i edit my
pictures and face tune them just because
it just gives them that extra like
feeling to the picture
but not like enhanced like nose or eyes
or anything like that
that's the same thing i'd smooth the
texture unless you see me in person
honey you're not going to see these
scars or
this texture or anything like that i'm
going to filter it out
i used to be uh i had a low self-esteem
so i was really crazy with like
you know the photoshopping and
everything and as i grow into myself i
just grew to love
but as far as filtering like my makeup
looks or whatever um
there's always going to be a little
smooth here and there a woman's hair is
fully christmas
it's cool it does something i always
think a little smooth here
i guess the reason why i asked that
question is because in a lot of like
makeup ads
they'll do the makeup look and then
change the makeup look in photoshop but
it just seems like it sets unrealistic
expectations a for the product and b
what it's going to make you look like
i just maybe maybe i'm missing i just
don't get the whole like
love yourself naturally and then do all
these enhancements and modifications to
your face like
it's fine if your self-esteem and your
sense of confidence comes from the fact
that you don't look like how you look
when you're home by yourself and just
chilling like i don't know to me that
just seems like such a poor basis it's
such a poor basis for ourselves
i got a hard time whenever you say uh
you play on words no no i grew into
myself
i that's my true self that is there's a
lot of people out there that are like
yeah love yourself love your body
be yourself and then you went through
all these enhancements
and i ain't got no problem with
enhancement i don't give a [ __ ]
but when you do the enhancement and then
you claim that you're natural and you
claim that
that's you it's not it's just not and
that's you being part of the problem
but whatever i digress i just don't
understand the whole like
now i love myself now that i fixed my
nose or whatever it's just like
okay this is the very idea that you're
shelling out money
to reach this like standard of beauty or
get closer to it to make yourself feel
more comfortable in your own body
is by definition you not loving who you
are
and needing to change it but that's me
since i am like
all over social media and like tv and
stuff when people
expect me to show up and show face they
expect to glam and they expect the
makeup
and if i do show up without any of that
it's just like no one that's like
where's the star where's the star power
where's la demi you know
your makeup look do you guys use filters
on them
i've always been open with all my
followers that i edit my pictures
and face tune them through the texture
unless you see me in person honey you're
not going to see these scars or
this texture or anything like that i'm
gonna filter it out
like a superpower i always say makeup
because when i when i'm
in makeup i just feel like i have a cape
on and i can do anything
um when i have makeup i just feel like i
could conquer like the whole world
there is no harm in children using
makeup
wow
yeah presley oh
wow it's harmful for
unless there's some kind of health
effect that i'm unaware if you're
staying back that means you don't think
that you're saying that that means you
think there's something wrong no kids
there's no arm when when you go up you
agree
okay there's no yes so everyone's
staying back they're saying
there is harm which is interesting like
well if there's harm for kids why
wouldn't it be harm for adults
i don't think it works like that why not
i think it works like why not because
because that might be harm but the arm
the arm is
i believe that if the kids using makeup
there is definitely more harm than
whenever
why because of the setting because of uh
the possibility there's more
possibilities
that the that the kids have arm than
than adults
how it affects your perception that you
go into this mind where
you just think that you uh you you just
need it if you're talking about looking
at yourself in self-esteem issues yeah
if you're saying it could be harmful to
kids then why wouldn't it be harmful to
adults
it's them applying it to themselves at
the degree that they know but but you
know porn is good for adults
uh not for kids it doesn't mean that it
would harm
idols i'm diving i'm going into your
direction right now
because even it's not good for kids but
it can harm
the same way porn can the same way i get
what you're saying because someone would
say like yeah but
good for for adults but whatever yeah it
can
i want to hear how they think it's going
to be harmful yeah be sure to leave a
like a comment you know youtube's not
always fond of us so it helps out the
algorithm
that's pretty good so the way that i
interpreted this question was children
doing their own makeup
not having it done by someone older
or someone who's more experienced with
it i think that makeup within itself
is a self-expression and i feel that if
a young boy or a young girl is drawn to
that
then it should be supported and
treated with like love and kindness and
acceptance
i think it's totally fine
if a kid has conscious parents maybe
conscious friends
mentors teachers around them and they're
just playing with makeup
and your their intent is not simply to
please others i think it's
completely fine i've just noticed that
that doesn't tend to happen a lot of
times in society
literally everybody adults who came up
here said they do it on social media
they touch up their photos
because they are doing it for the world
they're not doing it for themselves
so if you think that is a harmful thing
then it's also harmful to the adults why
would it be just harmful to the kids
you got a point there i don't really
have a strong opinion on this specific
topic i'm just thinking about the
logical consistency
the first steps and this one right here
if you're saying oh no kids can't handle
it what is it that they can't handle you
saying there's nothing wrong with makeup
that's what i don't understand but it
could affect adults
the same way it affects kids i just want
to hear how it affects the kids i don't
understand
i wouldn't want my little sister wearing
makeup so young
because i wouldn't want her to attract
the wrong attention isn't that
considered victim blaming
don't go there oh i'm not i'm not even
trying to joke
they didn't really demonstrate to me how
putting on makeup
as a kid is very drastically different
than putting on makeup as an adult
if you feel like it's harmful for adults
or not harmful then it should be fine
for the kids if you
allow them to rock around these booty
shorts and you know showing a bit of
cleavage and doing all this other stuff
right and they do that i go to dance
competitions i'll be seeing it sometimes
i'm like
and i'm not saying i want these things
to happen my whole point is i don't
understand why there's like a random
lawn dry and i hear it for makeup but
then
the clothing can be whatever it wants
that's that's the weird part the
clothing is really the clothing when
they dance they're not
when they wear their makeup they wear
makeup more more than when they dance
you know i mean they limited the dancing
basically what i'm trying to say is that
there's a correlation between i think
that's how they think
there's a correlation between sex and
makeup
so you don't want kids to be sexualized
like that it's not everybody that's okay
with the kids dancing but you said it's
just when they dance that's not true
they're wearing booty shorts everywhere
what are you talking about they're
wearing the lou lemon yoga pants
everywhere
who kids kids teen young teenagers yes
no but they don't they don't fit the
same way that lululemon fits it's not
i don't think it's the same thing you're
not going to walk off the street with a
pony pin printer
maybe i haven't seen what i've seen but
i've seen that setting in
a setting of uh dancing
but not booty shorts of course yes young
girls today are far more
in terms of their wardrobe sample sanji
it's a complaint that people have every
day
they always talk about how young kids
today are dressing like crazy
mom okay it's not just a special thing
you guys can leave comments below if i'm
wrong but i mean
you see it everywhere even the movie
cuties kind of showed that that when
these girls
not just at their competition but when
they're walking around they were wearing
these clothes you don't remember that in
the movie yeah but i remember that from
back then too what do you mean
though it was kid that was it's it's not
but you said it's only at the
competition
what i mean is them wearing sexual
clothes not just at the competition
but the thing that happened is that you
try to limit that and then with the
makeup on top of that
you're adding a layer which is very
you're just adding a layer on top of it
okay but okay let's say i agree with you
okay let's agree with you let's say
it is does that mean that when all adult
women are wearing it they're trying to
sexualize themselves there's a
correlation there's a correlation
so me to me whenever you wear makeup
there is you try to be
you try to look better and looking
better there's a correlation with
sexuality
than when you wear makeup it is all
right well listen i'm not going to deny
the idea because the colors of the
makeup and everything is really just
like
emulating the mating of animals and
stuff like that you know what i mean
when they have more colors to attract
the other you're trying to attract
there's an attraction an
attraction thing so there's a
correlation definitely okay so i'm not
i'm not going to deny the scientific
link between certain forms of makeup and
like
the effect on you know the sexual
marketplace that's not what i'm saying
what i'm trying to get at and i think
the initial point is these are arbitrary
lines that we're drawing in regards to
saying like makeup is somehow harmful
because of this or that and then there's
also the whole vic like oh i don't want
these dudes to be attracted to you well
will we say that to adults will we say
that to young teenagers is that the
message that we want to send
and i'm not saying that i want these
things to happen or i want them to
become a trend or norm i don't
i don't think it's a good thing no but i
see your point there but i do think that
these lines are arbitrary they don't
make much sense
i also don't think they understand how
harmful that messaging is because what
you internalize in them as young teens
also they're going to keep on with
themselves later on if you tell them
you need to make yourself smaller so
people well that's the same message i'm
going to have an adult are you going to
have that same attitude then
i question that so that's just one thing
makeup has changed how i'm treated by
people
pre-covered days i love to go out to
dance and stuff to go to the club
just men tend to just give me a lot more
attention
when i'm wearing makeup and i don't know
it just doesn't
feel it doesn't feel good to me
yeah of course
i mean if you came out with double d's
instead of a cups that'll probably give
you more attention
it's kind of how it functions we all
know what's happening and i swear
and i'm not wearing it not a peep comes
no one no one comes my way i think i
like the latter i like
no one coming up to me since i am like
all over social media and like tv and
stuff when people
expect me to show up and show face they
expect to glam and they expect the
makeup
and if i do show up without any of that
it's just like no one that's like
where's the star where's the star power
where's la demi you know
i kind of feel the same way on social
media all i
have on is makeup and then on my normal
days i'm like just a regular boy so when
i go to like sephora or makeup shopping
they're just like oh
is he gonna steal something because you
know something that's what they mostly
think of when you're not like in full
glam or you look bummy or he's
to steal something because he's looking
suspicious looking at it because you
just look dark skinned if you don't have
your makeup
when you do have your makeup you dark
skin but flamboyant i'm like oh okay
that's why
so are you saying that the makeup helps
them get away from oppression
yeah i guess i said exactly that um so
i've definitely gone into interviews or
like heard my employer talk about people
and it's not that they'll say like oh
she wasn't wearing makeup they'll say
like
she didn't seem as ready or like she
wasn't as put together i used to only
wear makeup
pretty much for interviews or if i was
on camera i didn't want to give them a
reason to not hire me
smart lady yeah she's right yeah you
know listen i'm not going to tell
somebody not to wear makeup or to
not do plan to do whatever you want but
if you know the game but yeah
but she's right it's like i'm not gonna
be mad at you because you used it to get
a job because i understand that's the
way the world is built and it's
unfair right i don't like wearing suit
and ties but when i needed to work at gp
morgan chase
i wore what i needed to wear there you
go gotta do what you gotta do so smart
girl
like a super power i always say makeup
because when i
when i'm in makeup i just feel like i
have a cape on and i can do anything
and without it it kind of humbles me
down to maybe
not be that person in the room to ask a
question or you know it's kind of like
my backup dancer
yeah so you only feel comfortable being
out
you know this person is also trans so
there's probably a heightened difference
you know because of the fact that like
you know if people can really tell that
you're trans
maybe they treat the person differently
and they just want it so maybe that's
like
comes into it so maybe i'm just kidding
there's more levels to what she's saying
then yeah because hurts it's not a cis
woman would go about and just wear
not wear makeup there's more levels to
[ __ ] so that's right to a reality so i
can understand that but i'm glad that
you pointed out
yeah i agree um with la demi um when i
have makeup i just feel like i could
conquer like the whole world and i'm
just like that person that can do
anything
that's like the main reason why i go
into makeup because it just makes you
feel good don't you feel like
short guys wish there was makeup to make
them taller so they could just feel that
way sometimes when they go out
you imagine if you were five six and you
get to put on some makeup that made you
six too
and you get to walk around like i can
conquer the world i know what it feels
like to be a tongue because at least
i mean there's nothing you could do with
your weight and yeah unless you just put
high heels and stuff like that or
platform and stuff like that but at
least if you're sure
you just just put everything that you
yeah put on yourself
if you flawless flawless you still got
good genes you look like you got a good
team
cause that i did it today that's what
makeup is right looking like you got
them good jeans exactly
yeah so instead of like makeup for short
people would be like leg up you know
instead of makeup
you know just something that like you
know like lifts in the shoes or
something something that looks natural
though like it looks like they got long
legs
you know what i'm saying right guys
would you
if you were if you were five six right
five seven and somebody offered you a
product called leg up okay
it was societally accepted we wouldn't
look at you like you're an idiot okay
and you walked around like you were six
two do it ready to play the end
would you do it to go outside they do it
they do it
knock it out that's what kind of
question is this oh of course they do it
yeah
yeah and imagine the girls like what's
your shoe size uh size 8 us
but g65 yeah kind of tip over when [ __ ]
i'm rocking leg ups like why [ __ ] you
walking
rocking makeup shut up i just believe
sorry eight shoes hey man listen that's
a good product somebody can make leg ups
for short men they do have a surgery
though that
stretches your your legs oh that's uh
dangerous yes it is
i have felt uncomfortable leaving home
without makeup
when i started to wear makeup and i was
you know being perceived
to the public as a woman without it i
wasn't
you know so it was like really hard to
adjust to
even leaving my house without a lash
without an eyebrow without some kind of
lip gloss or blush or
something to give me that touch to feel
like you know i'm not going to get
misgendered out there in the world
i am trans and i definitely know what it
feels like to
not be able to leave the house without
something like
one of them sis girls that leave without
makeup is just she's not
gonna feel let's say that she's gonna
look good or whatever
if she doesn't feel if she doesn't wear
makeup
she doesn't feel like what she she
doesn't feel
well she doesn't get treated she is
treated right right
when she's out there and she doesn't
fully present as a woman in terms of the
whole makeup and all that stuff
that's her definition of it yeah she
doesn't get treated as such
i mean you know whether she wears makeup
or not to me it's kind of clear that
this person's trans but i just wouldn't
treat them differently
yeah but um yeah i could i could see
that she gets misgendered because i just
felt like i trusted her i just knew that
i could trust her so funny to like
bounce off of that i went through like a
phase two where like
i would like spend the night with a guy
and i would not take off my makeup
like i was sleeping my makeup and even
like 10 minutes before like waking up
waking up i would run back to the
restroom
touch up put on a lip stain so i would
wake up like
i used to before we were boyfriend and
girlfriend
i used to sleep in my makeup and makeup
all over this dude's pillow
so on valentine's day
thanks a lot ruining my [ __ ] i think the
only time i used to regularly wear
makeup is like if i thought i'd see my
ex or something like that
but also when i was going on a lot of
first dates before i met my girlfriend i
would like
it would pretty much be the only time
i'd wear makeup like i wouldn't wear it
to work and i would come home and put it
on
but then i started to realize like these
people like if it goes further they're
going to see me without makeup and i'd
almost
rather have them know that up front and
actually the first date i went on with
my girlfriend was like one of the first
first dates i didn't wear makeup
yeah that's interesting sometimes i'll
be like going out with girls
sometimes i'll be talking beforehand
like maybe like we'll face time once or
twice and
so no i can't face i don't know my
makeup but i'm like listen if we're
gonna date seriously i'm gonna see you
without makeup it's like it's kind of i
already think you're attracted it's not
that big of a deal
but you know for some guys maybe they
would go like ew you don't so maybe
that's why they feel uncomfortable part
of it but
i'm like yeah just if someone's going to
leave you because you don't look at your
best without makeup then
they're probably not going to be that
into you to begin with but that's just
true thoughts
straight up and the last thing i would
say is like yo listen as far as this
video goes i have no issue with anything
i don't have an issue with any of the
contests i thought they were great they
were wonderful
and i thought the casting the questions
were very pertinent so good job to to
jubilee for that but
um i think it does raise some
interesting questions and i think
they weren't fully being honest with
maybe they're not with themselves either
with what the implications are when they
put on makeup
because their messaging didn't make
sense based off of like the ideas that
they were exposing
so that was a confusing part for me if
you're saying okay i love myself and
this helps me be myself then why
wouldn't you allow that for young
teenagers
that's what you said it does for you
fully growing into yourself
yeah she said she needed that to be
comfortable stuff but then you wouldn't
offer that to young teenagers
because it might be the same case for
young young women i don't agree with it
but that's what you said right so
that's why i kind of had some issues
with it but otherwise i thought it was
cool it was like insightful and i got to
learn something so
whenever they say this these those
things are in these discussions there's
nobody that
chime in like that they chime in or
maybe it was edited out i don't know
but yeah no i see what you're saying in
your points with that the last the
consistency and stuff like that yeah i
could definitely see it where i'm like
but it's not what i think it's really
what you and it's really what they said
so if you allow yourself to grow
into your full sub then yeah no i see i
yeah it was just those at first at first
i didn't get it and i was
the more i was thinking about it i was
trying to clean it i was like
yeah that's that's always been my issue
with the whole like a bit of the body
positivity movement or something like
this like no judgment you know stuff
like this i'm like
what do you mean or even when they they
talked about like uh i do makeup for
myself
you know i don't make these alterations
for anybody else so i'm like huh you
literally started the video by saying
you made alterations
to your instagram pictures because
that's what people needed that when you
went out
they were expecting you to look some
kind of way they're expecting pop and
glam
so you had to present a cert so that is
you doing it for others
whenever you have a rhetoric like that
you don't hear your message yeah you
don't hear yourself saying it so yeah
you contradict yourself and you without
even
knowing it yeah so i generally don't i'm
not a big fan of when people say stuff
like i'm doing it for myself and we all
know most of the time that's not true
and it's okay it's okay to do things for
others because you want to be accepted
and liked that's fine
but let's stop lying about what it is
it's like i don't understand that
but that's just me personally nobody so
those are my thoughts you have any other
thoughts
no but it makes sense but you think it
makes sense yeah what do you guys think
in the comments below we want to hear
your thoughts do you guys agree disagree
oh
my